[Music]
[Music]
welcome everybody you know i'm excited
to announce here today with my good
friend hassan
uh here in our 20 billion dollar
underground bunker that's right that our
ppp loan
leftovers inc our ppp loan was
officially forgiven today hell yeah baby
yep
we actually were able to regain all 20
billion dollars that we used for the
bunker it was all forgiven today yeah
yep and if you
want to regain your student loan debt if
you want any kind of loan relief [ __ ]
you
pick yourself up by your goddamn
bootstraps why don't you work harder
and and not do that and not suck on the
government titty
yeah there's been a lot of that i've
actually really enjoyed
all the harvard phd's and literal
billionaires yeah like mitt romney who
are like this is an outrage that
students are getting 10 000 out of debt
um mitt romney
you're worth half a billion dollars like
have you
do you know anything about debt at all
like shut the [ __ ] shut your mouth [ __ ]
uh my favorite was obama uh obama
administration uh uh you know econ
advisor jason furman
uh who went on to complain about it
obama of course
liberals liberals are
first of all obama already had like a
[ __ ] load of goldman sachs people in his
in his cabinet which was awful to begin
with right
shouts out to obama thanks obama thank
you
and yeah
we are all domestic terrorists so so
that was already annoying so he he goes
on the timeline and he's like blasting
it and because it's like an obama
administration person
yeah maybe it doesn't work if you're
oh zach's gone so okay it's a little
dicey yeah you just
all you did was cut them off yeah no
well abs still recovering from the
[ __ ]
you know awful thing that he had to have
last week
thank you um thank you son but
in any case
uh he came out on the timeline everyone
was like oh my god like look this is a
former obama guy like oh drama right
obama but like biden what's going on
there
and um and then i immediately i was like
all right let's take a look let's take a
look at what this dude's background is
of course harvard graduate
his gr his father went to harvard his
father was a real estate developer right
and guess what his grandfather was doing
also a real estate developer oh my god
that's so crazy it's like yeah [ __ ]
you obviously don't give a [ __ ] because
you think you [ __ ] earned it how did
you earn it by being born into a family
that already had legacy admission and
like your your harvard admission was
like set the moment you were [ __ ]
born they bought a gymnasium or some
[ __ ] so his ass could go to harvard yeah
this man has never even known someone
who was this man everyone in his orbit
is probably disgustingly wealthy you
know what i mean
this man has never known a middle-class
person in his life and of course his
brother is also a federal judge also
appointed
wow like it's just these guys like
we talk about nepotism right and like
obviously you know i'm i'm nepotism andy
i i you know i
worked with uncles a 26 person uh you
know youtube startup by the way people's
name is going to harvard people do say
you're a nepotism baby
but
i will say in your defense obviously
i don't remember i mean you were on
twitch building your own your own uh
empire i mean yeah i mean you didn't
rise the ranks through yeah i didn't i
didn't blow up because i mean this i
mean i have emails from him begging me
to come on the show literally begging
and kissing my ring i was like ethan
please i love you i'm such a big fan and
i didn't even respond because i didn't
know who the [ __ ] he was yeah exactly
like the the whole like
young turks jake's nephew didn't work
not at all did nothing for me um yeah
and now i'm you know now
have i ever read large emails
i don't know i think we might have
looked at it i think we looked at it
maybe on the podcast yeah early on this
hat is really itchy good it's horrible
i'm gonna i'm taking it off i'm going
through with it oh it is it's too itchy
for me i'm sorry um hold on i want to
find one hassan [ __ ] but yeah i
yeah i mean i i am a nephism baby i mean
i'm a beneficiary of nepotism i
i admit that i mean my parents my
parents paid for
oh we read them already yeah okay all
right okay my parents paid for my
college i paid i paid for some for the
last year yeah no i i look i i had
student loan debt i paid mine off
uh it was not easy to do but
i would i'm i don't know i would never
be like huh i suffered so you should too
like that's [ __ ] psychotic
you're just trying to cut policy off of
being selfish like yeah so that's that's
the main talking point i see people
saying about the student loan debt
forgiveness is like what about the
people that already paid off their debt
it's like
great they know how shitty it is and and
most normal human beings i think that
would probably feel like uh others
should not have to go through that
i mean you could say that about so many
things though right yeah i gotta say
that about people who you know
there's a tick talk about uh there's a
there's a black girl in tiktok that made
a a joke about that exactly about
talking about like the underground
railroad and like the abolition of
slavery
and and how uh you know it's like
no one is gonna say like oh well we had
to we had to escape
and now you're just going to abolish
slavery across the board like that
um yeah or you know oh well
i
uh
i had cancer and i had to survive it was
really difficult with chemo but now
there's a vaccine uh no everyone should
go through that yeah it's just like so
stupid
and as far as debt goes um i mean
debt relief is pretty commonplace and
that debt should not even exist in the
first place because you shouldn't have
to pay to go to college you should not
have to pay to become a more productive
member of the workforce so
you know i mean there's been there's
like massive [ __ ] corporate handouts
all the time and the one time it
actually goes i read this factoid which
is very interesting because this never
happens 70
of the like i don't know how much is it
300 billion or something that they're
giving to uh 329 billion over 10 years
yes so the estimate 70 70 of it is going
to people who earn less than 75 000 a
year or something yeah that's that's
[ __ ] good economics you know what's
when you [ __ ] up no no listen to this
though because jason furman had
something for that too and he was like
well they're making less than 75 grand
right now but that means they're
probably going to make far more than
that in the future it's like dude
yourself over literally 10 years
i just you can't say stuff that you
could say on on youtube right that you
couldn't sound there's they're like you
can say anything but this see you next
tuesday and slurs oh so i could like be
like
no i can't say like you know
the world would be where it is
just for the sake of uh
yeah appearance
pecker is mad yeah i am not saying kill
yourself to anyone no
on this broadcast minecraft or ever at
all i would never do that
jump off a mountain in minecraft but it
does it does roll off the tongue really
well sometimes especially for certain
particular individuals or you just like
wanna you wanna let out your frustration
and say that but
yes so 70 of this money is going to
people who earn less than like 75 000 a
year and that's incredible for welfare
programs because usually with these big
government handouts like example the ppp
this was just like a cash [ __ ] frenzy
for super wealthy companies i mean in
sane right and and and
these same people that by the way the
ppp program cost a trillion dollars
nearly and for the record just just
so we clarify something here like there
was good that came out of the ppp low on
program a lot of people were able to pay
their employees and not [ __ ] fire
them immediately or not do like budget
cuts right so
i'm not i'm not i'm not criticizing that
program i'm only saying as an example
that with this one trillion dollar cash
frenzy that went like the vast majority
to super rich companies
a vast majority as we'll show you guys
are these conservatives who are
criticizing the student loan forgiveness
program uh it's it's they have nothing
to [ __ ] complain about but the minute
that you're actually bailing out people
who are in and student debt is a it's a
legitimate crisis i mean every 2.7
trillion dollars
it's unbelievable and and by the way the
amount of people that i know personally
there's more people that have student
debt than not the amount of debt these
people have is insane you're literally
crushing the rising class uh a future
working class of this country with un
unsurmountable debts okay that is by
design ethan
um well that is lit quite literally on
purpose it's the same exact principle as
employer-backed insurance programs
uh it is a way to make sure that there
is a permanent underclass of work for
everybody yeah i know but like become
everybody
it's not everybody because like them
it's
incredibly wealthy don't have to go
through that or are not shackled or
burdened in the same in the same way
that like a middle class family is
though because education is the
most
education is the common denominator for
upward social mobility right
so you are you are essentially
ensuring and this is something that
ronald reagan's advisor
uh uh talked about all the way back when
ronald reagan was a governor when he
moved to privatize or at least offer
tuition
at the uc's in the university of
california because it used to be free
up until the 70s new year california was
free yeah ronald reagan's advisor very
famously said and he worked for nixon as
well very famously said ensuring that
everyone has a college education is
going to have a serious is going to
create serious problems in the future in
the long term because you will have an
educated working class
which then will be able to more
effectively
communicate their demands more
effectively fight back
and also will be harder to control and
someone needs to still clean the toilets
basically he didn't say that but i mean
here i have the quote it's we are in
danger of producing an educated uh
proletariat that's dynamite we have to
be selective on who we allow to go
through higher education i think
probably what they fear is that people
with a higher education tend to lean
more
democratic and for you know for
everything for them is just political
points so you have to keep people dumb
and angry for them to vote republican or
not that's one that's one nobody
whatever
that's that's certainly one component of
it but like i said it's it's because
they're also worried about unemployment
why are they worried about unemployment
because
the more educated people are the less
likely they are going to you know take
janitorial positions like positions are
profoundly important
however
um easy to cycle through
because uh there's there's a lower
barrier of entry there's not a lot of
like skills you need to learn you can
learn on the job so these are seen as
replaceable jobs even though we consider
them essential because they are
essential um
if if they are no longer seen as like
easily replaceable then or if there is a
lot of uh shortages there because a lot
of people are now skilled skilled
laborers um all of a sudden you're gonna
have to pay them more and you can't have
or allow immigrants profit margin some
[ __ ] right i mean yeah
i mean that's a real thing right i mean
if you stop immigration
it stops a lot of these low-skill
entry-level jobs from getting filled no
well um
immigration is is certainly the way that
like uh both parties utilize uh the the
permanent underclass like there is a
there's a constantly refilling pool of
undocumented labor
that you can kind of use as a
you can use and abuse and then and then
cast aside when they ever uh ask for
like back pay or ever complain about
like sexual harassment right there are
many such examples of this like purdue
is one of the best examples that comes
to mind the purdue chicken factory
like they purposely uh
bake into their profit margins uh
they they seek after undocumented
immigrants they go to undocumented
immigrant communities they resettle them
and then
the moment that they ask for any sort of
back pay
uh because their wedges are being stolen
or better workplace safety conditions
they call ice on themselves
and then boom back to rehiring uh that's
cool yeah so they do that
that's just good business but of course
tucker carlson and other right-wingers
will look to that and say that's why we
need to shut off uh you know our borders
or whatever but the real solution is not
necessarily to
stop immigration from happening
it's to streamline the process and
ensure that undocumented workers are
documented
and are able to advocate for better
workplace conditions and organize
alongside the rest of the documented
labor force that's how you get a bigger
piece of the pie not by
trying to shut off the border because
that's not very that's never going to
happen anyway
yeah but i i just don't
i have a hard time with that i mean i
know these guys are like smart
economists and [ __ ] and they went to
harvard and all that and that's all
impressive credentials but
it doesn't make sense to me when you the
so-called proletariat doesn't have
enough [ __ ] money to buy to consume
any products that's the second society
[ __ ] does not our capitalist society
does not function when people are
so consumed by debt that they can't
consume anything
yeah and in my opinion that's what's
going to be the downfall of this country
is that you know the this the
disparaging uh amounts of wealth
basically it's going to cause this
country to stop being able to function
when people are too poor they can't
[ __ ] buy anything they can't support
themselves they can't do anything and
there's people just sitting on literal
[ __ ] hordes of gold like smog
from [ __ ] bill from the goddamn uh
hobbit
you know
ethan you're quite
you're quite literally describing at
least one component of
a famous theorist
whose name is karl marx and this is this
is my boy smog right there man the
falling
you're describing the falling rate of
profit and and profits tendency to fall
like that's that you literally described
one component of that
but so it's just so it's such a basic
self-apparent thing that
i i don't know if i'm missing something
when all these think tanks these
incredible think tanks these people have
phds from harvard and super high
institutions they don't
they don't ever take that into account
or maybe
they maybe they do they do that's this
is
this exact this thing that you're
talking about is a part of it maybe they
do and what they consider like poverty
is way way it's like you know
being able to stay alive
like feed yourself that's like where
they want you to be precisely and not
any higher than that
yeah they're they're just they're
they're as profit as a consequence of
technological achievements
uh becomes uh the profit margins become
narrower and narrower
and and uh in order to do that you have
to exhaust your working class to make
sure that you're not paying them too
much
um because you have to make up for that
profit somewhere and without labor there
is no profit there is no value um
what you look for is automation and then
what you look for is like different
shortcuts of trying to make someone make
the average worker work more right
um
and in turn you have less purchasing
power so when you the average worker
have less purchasing power
then you can't sell the products that
you're making to begin with who's going
to buy the [ __ ] products like you
mentioned yeah
so it's this never-ending cycle of
trying to figure out exactly how how
much you can starve out the the working
class without ensuring that they are so
starved that they recognize that they're
backed into a corner and have to fight
back well they're way off bro
in terms of like where that bar is but
you know back back to the student debt
thing
i mean ten thousand dollars is obviously
not a lot for most people with student
debt in this country but you know it's a
good thing and i'm happy they did it
obviously and and you know it's a big
relief to the people that need it most
yeah it's it's certainly a mechanism of
control though i need to i need to
mention this uh i can't stress this
enough
if you go to college you're talking
about student then yes you go to college
to become a more productive worker right
across the board everyone is doing that
so they can become a more productive
laborer your output is better overall
right you're a skilled laborer your
output's better this in turn builds the
economy this grows the economy it's a
very this is a very good thing right
overall it's so good that in other
countries they literally pay you to go
to college in certain countries right
yeah that's that's how that's how much
people know yeah that's how necessary
education is
so
um in america however
they saddle you with debt so that even
if you have improved yourself even if
even if you become a more skilled
laborer by getting an education
right
they saddle you with debt so you just
take on whatever [ __ ] job you can
right after college because you have to
start paying it really a grand design or
is it just like the natural consequence
of unchecked capitalist grade you know
what i mean like i have a hard time
thinking it's some grand design but when
things are going in the direction that
people in power are comfortable with
they don't do anything to stop it and
it's like
the the schools charge more
more and more and more and yet still if
they once they start looking at a
business they go well still we're
getting more applications than ever
turning away more people than ever our
acceptance rate is lower than ever so
they see these [ __ ] cycles that are
now running these
these uh universities go well we can
raise the price because there's so much
demand yeah and i think i think
that um
it's just i don't i don't know that it's
a grand plan but people are happy to
live the grand plan is capitalism
they're just they're just engaging in
profit-seeking behavior and it's normal
for them to do this
if you don't ascribe a moral value to it
then it's just capitalism of course
they're going to do that businesses are
going to do whatever the [ __ ] they can
to make more money colleges are
businesses that's that's so that's where
it gets so [ __ ] up is where these
you know these these universities were
built
and have this incredible reputation you
know when when my dad was young me and
dan talked about this our dads are
probably similar ages
my dad went through ucla and paid it off
with like a [ __ ] part-time minimum
wage job yeah my dad was in the 70s he
went to ucsd and yeah i think it was
right before uh the change happened that
you were talking about and yeah i think
he just paid like incidental costs i
think he paid just a couple thousand
dollars to get a degree that's why i
love when boomers that's why i love when
[ __ ] boomers come out and they're
like why can't you just pay you know
what why can't you guys stop eating the
avocado toast like yeah bro yeah okay
grandpa like
it's so pathetic but the thing is like
these colleges built their this
reputation
and
i don't think they would have ever
become what they are if they were
charging this [ __ ] from the beginning
um
it's just it's insane i don't know
what's going on with that it's just
[ __ ] up and on the other hand the
government is so happy to give the least
responsible people in the world newly
turned 18 year old sometimes 17 year
olds
[ __ ] unfathomable amounts of debt
we're talking hundreds of thousands of
dollars people that can't even open a
credit card because they have no [ __ ]
credit
and not only that the interest rates
like when i had student loans the
interest rates were catastrophic i'm
talking one of them had like 11 i mean
what kind of [ __ ] help is that i mean
they're also really fond of getting uh
18 year olds they're they're they're
really fond of signing 18 year old
contracts yeah uh the military
that's exactly how it offers isn't it
great that like visa is like nah dude we
don't trust you with a hundred dollar
credit card you don't have enough credit
you don't have enough uh you haven't
proven that you're responsible enough
and then the government's like here's
two hundred thousand dollars that you
can never get rid of through even
through bankruptcy
yeah no that's that's that's why i said
is by design because that debt makes you
more servile it's just the truth uh just
like
um there's an a there's an opportunity
to make money but it's it's just like
it's doubly efficient is what i'm saying
that's why the government doesn't
actually uh take serious uh
steps to to combat it that's that was
what i was saying is like right
deliberate mechanism behind it um same
with the same with employer-based
insurance like you're not going to leave
your job even if you're unhappy
if you're [ __ ] like actual
potential uh health is attached to it
it's just a way to keep you working at
the same job even if you hate it
uh you have no you have no way of like
making lateral moves ever because you're
just terrified that if you lose your job
you lose your health care right it's
inhumane right
right um
so that's how that's how this [ __ ] works
yeah but
basically just to go back i mean
it's it's so demonic to even say such a
thing as like what about the people that
paid their debt it's like do you really
[ __ ] are you really comfortable
saying that publicly like listen to
actually what you're saying they are we
don't want to help other people
yeah period because you've done this
because uh you know it's like dude what
the [ __ ] and these are all religious
people too like that's a very
christ-like stance to take well this guy
did it so we don't want to help anybody
else
yeah i dunked on uh this veteran
uh that runs the code vector
idiot just did you did you see that no i
mean that's this basically what i said
uh i don't know if you want to pull it
up it's like pull it up all right hassan
dubs let's follow yeah code of vets uh
it's it's on my profile it's just i i
quote tweeted it
and slammed her dominant get ready guys
we got hassan dubs on twitter
i got a couple big ones yesterday oh by
the way i forgot to say at the top of
the show
we have a yeah we have a pizza frozen
pizza taste test because the song was
stepping to me
continually saying that frozen pizza
sucks being classy says [ __ ] yeah you
think why do you eat frozen pizza well
we brought a bunch of frozen pizzas and
i even warned you yesterday i said save
some calories you [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
what what
what you use it use
you you animal you beast no i was gonna
say like
bro you got i don't know what to say you
can be healthy and also be like i can
take a bite of this pizza without
ruining my week you know i just i'm i'm
obsessive though and i cause i know like
uh certain things just like break me
yeah but you're not getting out of this
i warned you ahead of time i know i know
i said i would do it i said that with
calories are you you carve them out did
you carve out calories for this uh i
just well i'm going to carve out
calories later in the day for it yes
he has no pizza i have a i have a tactic
like 500 calories here here's the here's
the dunk are we thinking 500 calories
for this or i'm gonna try to max out at
300. 300. i'm going to take like one
healthy enough bite from each individual
pizza one bite it's all it takes you
know the rules um and and my tactic is
to like ensure that the total number of
by i see a lot more pizzas down there
there's a lot less
like okay well well i thought i could
track the calories so that uh i thought
i could just like take one bite and it'd
be like four pizzas so then it would
total like one singular slice but i
think it's gonna be probably like around
500 calories yeah it's fine okay good um
go ahead okay so code vets tweeted out
uh this this dumb thing where she said i
grew up in poverty in the mountains of
north carolina i ate out of a garden i
lived in government housing
already
shopped at yard sales i joined the air
force and earned my gi bill i attained
four degrees and created my own version
of the american dream i am not
responsible for your student debt why
are you so angry shut up [ __ ] i mean
i'm glad i know why she's angry because
this is exactly she's right
the government
institutes the [ __ ] poverty draft on
dummies like this okay get them while
they're young in the most like predatory
ways that you could you know create
child soldiers all right
that's the only way
no it's gross it's inhumane it's the
only way that the the army
that's their only opportunity a lot of
times yes exactly that's what i'm saying
it's the only way to get like
everybody understands that education is
the is the best way is the best method
to get upward social mobility
and if education is is basically
safeguarded
or gate kept to the elite to those who
can pay the only way you can get a
[ __ ] shitty communications degree and
then you know start a 501c3 for veterans
is by going and getting a communications
degree after you [ __ ] throw your body
i didn't celebrate i didn't hold to the
american government i didn't fight in
iraq and see my friends blown up so that
these hippies could have their [ __ ]
could get out of debt
yeah the one thing by the way that does
make me sometimes wonder if it is a
grand conspiracy if college was
affordable or free
nobody would ever join the military
that's what i'm saying ever and the
military already has recruitment issues
right now because the number one reason
why people joined the military was 9 11.
like that's it you can ask any recruiter
you can ask the military they will tell
you this openly 9 11. actually we hear
that a lot from from military people on
the show
exactly people joined there was a
massive uptick of people joining the
military after 9 11
and um and in the absence of another 911
911 2 electric boogaloo uh you know
you're not going to [ __ ]
people are not going to want to join
so you have to find different ways you
have to go to like you know
shitty neighborhoods underserved
neighborhoods you have to find the kids
with the bad grades
uh and and try to
try to suck them in by telling them they
get a [ __ ] dodge charger or camaro or
something
if they sign their soul to the military
industrial complex so i said america
shouldn't have to sell their bodies to
the imperialist forces working at the
behest of the military industrial
complex to get benefits most countries
offered to its citizens unconditionally
you [ __ ] dumb troglodyte
is what i said to her yeah i heard the
army actually set up a recruitment booth
at the local kindergarten there
i mean they they were doing really crazy
[ __ ] on twitter like they were offering
like [ __ ] xbox controllers and [ __ ]
to like 14 year olds if they promised
that they would like go bugs controllers
yeah that's a good investment for them
you know they kept trying to sponsor our
show and we always said nah yeah but
that would have been a juicy sponsorship
because oh my god the chinese army in
which case we will take it gg
yo what if china's like i'll give you a
i'll give you ten thousand dollars do it
for ten dollars dude
[ __ ] do it for 10.
my love for sale [ __ ] my loyalty is
cheap okay
it's uh as long as they build high-speed
rail a network of high-speed rail in the
united states oh my god i'm doing it
yeah take me take uh let's say uh uh
what's the [ __ ] word
i barely slept last night
what's the word when you goddamn take
someone's
yeah he slept he didn't sleep well last
night he didn't sleep well last night
because he was thinking about all the
all the [ __ ] kids that are going to
be able to now
not be saddled by 20 grand worth of dead
he was so mad he was like
crying i'm so angry
my college education why can't yours
yeah i don't know why they get so angry
just dude just like why do you need what
what it is i'm happy that something good
is happening to you right like let's
boil that down and then re and then like
understand
how [ __ ] insane it is to even be
publicly saying this i'm mad that
something good is happening for you
i mean this is america right so there
you have it
um but that is that is incredibly
american it's just like being deeply
selfish
and and they don't lose anything yeah it
doesn't even matter other people
get helped out a little bit yeah no it
doesn't matter
they say that they're going to be taxed
more no they're not right like that but
that's what they're i'm not saying that
that's true no but i think that that is
this is no because stupid you're taking
my money and keeping it going dummy this
is already this is debt the government
already paid for it shut the [ __ ] up
shut up [ __ ] you uh and no you know
what's gonna happen though you know
money is just money's like imaginary at
this point you know who's gonna suffer
refinancing companies and you know debt
you know uh debt uh refinancing
companies like restructuring companies
yeah those guys are gonna suffer a
little bit okay or the people that like
work off of uh securities in the same
way that like they did in the mortgage
uh in the housing price
like
people that securitize the debt and and
uh bet on it defaulting those people are
gonna know we need to help them
and and that's the problem it's
paramount that we help them
yeah
yeah so i don't know that's that um i
noticed you're wearing your friendship
bracelet i love that i have mine here
i just i don't like wearing hardware so
yeah hardware i'm just not right there
no it's cool it's like if you
you know you probably wear jeff and
mike's bracelet like all the [ __ ]
time no i don't bro i would wear i would
wear this yeah no sure sure it's much
more beautiful by the way yeah okay yeah
dude come on what's the [ __ ]
and i got news for you
that means you're friends
precisely
yeah so uh anyway there's so much more i
want to talk about
uh let's see ron desantis has uh [ __ ]
nightmarishly horrible ads we've seen a
lot of embarrassing ads i love that one
on this show
and i don't know
i don't know if conservatives really
have a monopoly on like the worst
[ __ ] ads you've ever seen
no democrats have some pretty bad ones
too
but um
you know it's it's america american
politics is is very
very bipartisan
find it
i challenge you to find a
democratic nominee with a
ad this cringy they do it all the time
if i want to see it i have right off the
top dome first of all the air force vet
[ __ ] is like the number one democratic
party in a red state move like they
always the democratic party loves like
finding a a queer-coded air force
veteran okay
who was gonna who's gonna raise like
seven garillion dollars off of every
wine mom in the country and then lose by
78 points to like mitch mcconnell that's
exactly who i was thinking of
amy mcgrath there you go i was trying to
name amy is the person i'm talking about
uh but they do it all the time they do
the whole like i
especially when it's air force like even
it blows my mind it's like i went and i
laser beamed 17 year old pakistani
children in the karenga valley okay
so now i deserve to be here in this
position i'm i'm more patriotic than
than the guy across the aisle for me
[ __ ] my eye was violently [ __ ] up
by uh
majid hadin
now i'll put the man okay let me see
this one but it's not like two million
views okay i've never seen this
fighter jets and land on aircraft
carriers because that's the toughest
line you can do
when i was 13 my congressman told me i
couldn't fly in combat
he said congress thought well yeah cause
you're 13.
you're like shut up dumbass you're 13.
i never got a letter back from my
senator mitch mcconnell
i then wrote every member of the house
and senate armed services committees
asking them to change the law
i said they just hadn't met me yet and i
knew i could do it but most of them told
me i couldn't she literally was like i
was incredibly annoying
you should vote for me because i was so
annoying at the age of 13. i was like i
need to be able to ser women should be
able to serve in the military as well
wait hold on i want to i want to see if
this i want to hear this okay because
i'm really going to do a comparison here
but this is a perfect comparison to the
desantis one it's like top gun versus
top gun yeah but this is like the
difference is of course she's like
actually top gun like she did top gun
[ __ ] which in my opinion is almost like
kind of worse because like
so she's literally like yeah i flew some
[ __ ] drones over uh a a you know
wedding in yemen not a big deal
i may or may not have bombed the
hospital in kunduz
let's see let's see let's see let's see
i'm amy mcgrath and i love our country i
spent 20 years as a us marine flew 89
combat missions bombing al qaeda oh yeah
yeah yeah you're right i [ __ ] hate
that i hate that so much she killed
civilians lots of them she's like i
killed
so many children so check out this
[ __ ] footage of me blowing up a
wedding yeah dude like go back let me
see that
i was i was holding out some hope for
her but this show gnarly she's like
ac130 incoming like let me see her
blowing up a mosque
89 combat missions bombing out
the taliban
you guys don't understand i blew up the
sudanese pill factory okay
i did that that was me [ __ ] go
back a little bit for me let me see her
bombing a kindergarten in iraq
the taliban yeah i was the first woman
that was an accident by the way yeah
so here's the other part of this though
pause for a second like
americans uh i mean this is a this is a
chapel take but whatever it's true
americans kind of understand that our
military doesn't win wars anymore so
like this kind of [ __ ] rhetoric isn't
even uh this kind of rhetoric is not
it doesn't hit like it doesn't hit like
it used to because there's no
ride on the world war two [ __ ] for so
long right uh the glories of world war
ii for so long when you're taking l
after l after l with from dudes wearing
[ __ ] sandals like no one's gonna give
a [ __ ] they're they're like okay shut up
loser who cares well it appeals to
conservatives but not not no it doesn't
that's what i'm saying everything there
well
i guess the the that's why
shooting [ __ ]
yeah but mitch mcconnell i mean come on
it's hard to beat the incantation of
satan himself but here's the thing mitch
mcconnell is awful for his state right
he's awful um but the difference is
when you try and make it seem as though
honestly that's not that bad could have
been worse what she she got
she got 38 percent blown the [ __ ] out
dude yeah by a guy who like barely goes
back to the state oh well you know
that [ __ ] could fly and i well yeah she
probably killed a bunch of [ __ ]
children [ __ ]
so that one lesbian is never the point
is this
democrats have been doing this since
john kerry since way before that like
they're like we're the real patriots
it's like no the moment that they find
you like windsurfing it's over they're
gonna say you're gay and no longer a
patriot okay oh swift boat swift boat
john kerry swift boat like boom it's
done
patriotism is
or at least the way that it's presented
to the american public is completely
owned by the right wing there is no such
thing you can never [ __ ] out patriot
the right because they will turn around
and say the n-word or something and be
like whoa look at how patriotic that guy
is you know what i mean i love it
oh whoa bro that guy's got seth hands
yeah he does yeah that's one of the top
left is that real yeah
that man is a sith do you want it yeah
you're like you lost wait
he's a cadaver this man is dead
how is this man's heart still beating
dude dude dude what and he has one of
those [ __ ] tapes that closes tape
wounds like a like an emergency the
thing on his hand yeah they you use
those the [ __ ] tape closed wounds bro
i'll show you i'll show you another
thing and you want to know why [ __ ]
mitch mcconnell is always going to be
perceived as more patriotic wait wait
wait wait wait wait hold on i'm not
getting over this okay you keep
you while you're looking at that
bro this is satanic this man is clearly
a homunculus he's been reincar
re-fucking animated do it i put it in
how can they accuse democrats of like
satanic rituals when you have a man
walking around with black hands
this is why mitch mcconnell here pulled
that up yeah this is why mitch mcconnell
will always be perceived as
significantly more patriotic than anyone
else you can put forward my man
cars and bars baby there was lots of
good men in the kkk and they did a lot
of good things for america shut up you
yeah but lesbian [ __ ] who is this by
the way that he's with
your mom uh i don't remember because i
think it is somebody like really
horrible yeah yeah yeah he is uh this is
a good this is a true blooded american
he is known for slaughtering
um
by the way go back to the hands
do we know what condition causes this no
i remember when it happened everybody
was very hush-hush about it but uh
there was some speculation that like
what condition causes your hands to turn
black old itis and you would like
reflect
death death that's what i think rigamore
is yeah abc when you reflect uh forced
lightning bro god is giving you a sign
my man it's saying [ __ ] die okay
that's what god's saying guys like come
on bro i'm trying to kill you what the
[ __ ] are you doing in congress no i'm
genuinely curious though this is wrong
um
there's gotta be a diagnosis for this so
i'm very curious hypertension someone
said diabetes yeah that makes sense
s or issirs can cause that shut up jade
no it doesn't
my hands aren't black
oh they're trying to i mean maybe it
does i think they're making a joke
wow
people say it's ligma
what's ligma
like my balls dude oh [ __ ] duck
destroyed
yeah so okay where were we that his
hands really threw me off
yeah you got we were getting to a
desantis's ad okay so wait let me finish
the top the top gun
yeah now i'm running for congress
against any bar in my home state of
kentucky he's mitch mcconnell's
hand-picked congressman who said he
would vote enthusiastically to take
health care away from over a quarter
million kentuckians
mr barr my mom is a polio survivor who
became one of the first women to
graduate from uk medical school a lot of
people told her she couldn't achieve her
dreams either but she persevered and
ended up treating many of the same kind
of people whose healthcare you and mr
mcconnell would take away
this is my new mission to take on a
congress full of career politicians who
treat the people of kentucky like
they're disposable
some are telling me a democrat can't win
that battle in kentucky
that we can't take back our country for
my kids and yours oh wait oh yeah that's
why i said queer quoted i didn't she's
not she's not
no she's not a lesbian
well that that woman's a lesbian also i
have no idea i swear it looks like so i
know
i know what a lesbian looks like and
she's one of them
but you're you're joking but like that
is literally what mitch mcconnell has to
say to like immediately secure everyone
in the state you know what i mean like
all
right
women should have long hair this is
outrageous you're really gonna hire this
woman who has a little short hair
yeah it's just like
that's why you cannot out woke you
cannot out patriot the [ __ ] right
because patriotism is not what you think
it is patriotism is not what you think
uh patriotism is not what you what has
been presented on television it's not
look besides the clips of her blowing up
iraqi soup kitchens
i think this one's worse
but let's watch a comparison
the the ad may be worse but uh the
things desantis did
in a different way are are certainly
just as easy i'm going to pee while you
play it i already saw it but i i have a
lot of thoughts
nah just wait we'll wait i'll wait for
you no i'll wait for you hassan i'm not
going to watch you without you
i'm not going to talk to myself what the
[ __ ] yeah
yeah take the opportunity thank you abe
the chat's been asking for the flock of
all morning yeah get it out get out of
your system what the hell are we going
to do without vloggers
flocka what you got some other good ones
in there you guys like my mitch
mcconnell
accent
i've been doing the you're mitchell
what a [ __ ] weasley little [ __ ]
dude you like my mitch mcconnell though
this weapon is clearly a love spread
decent it's pretty good it's pretty good
you think it's pretty good oh it's good
it's good listen uh when i when i was
three when i was 15 i met satan and i
told him give if i can become a powerful
politician
you can have my soul
and so from that day on i actually died
at 30. my corpse has been re re-animated
by satan himself
my note would be like
you're a little too
alive like he's a little more he's a
little more dead can you play a clip of
him sure yeah let me hear it especially
nowadays it's small which i can't only
don't have a lot of energy
talk about tacos
okay you did some good preparation uh
yeah he's stepping up stepping up
flocka that's good i like i like the
direction man
zach might have to keep that going um
after he gets flat oh he's punching the
air right now i don't know i don't know
do you think zach's going to erase the
flop oh daddy my own soundboard just for
[ __ ] yeah you that's it you can build
your own flop
a database that's even worse there's
gonna be you're starting you're planting
the seeds of a weasley little flock dude
you're playing the seeds of rebellion
right now in zack rebellion's reborn
today zack is gone so amy's been taking
over sound bites
and he struck on a really powerful one
which is the flakka meme which
everyone's everyone's enjoying
and we wonder if zach is gonna be pissed
about it
show me a video of mitch mcconnell real
fast i'm just seeing if my impression is
good or not responds i'm just mitch
mcconnell responds
it's a wife's duty to suck their
husband's [ __ ] at any time
every wife's duty to
suck their [ __ ] anytime they want that's
the whole point of marriage mcconnell
speaks you gotta you gotta really hit
the gullet because he's not
yeah his nussy is flapping his gum my
nussy is feeling is very tight and when
i put lubricant on it you'll think it's
a real real young tight pushy it's
flapping in the wind
like the sails of my yacht
i'll i let i like to let donald trump
rub his [ __ ] on my fluffy hey man
what is a plussy my my nussy my nazi
neck [ __ ] yeah
well waddle they should call that the
waddle too yeah let's see my let's see
all right i feel like with that you can
hit like way different slurs you know
what i mean
it's like a thing that
like old racist white guys can do you
can hit certain frequencies yeah you can
hit like a different like while tickling
your nussy you can hit like a different
slur that no one else could that's how
they that's actually how they figure out
who's going to be the next grand wizard
um
it's something they do at the uh yeah
the federalist society hits the races uh
you haven't earned your wings yet
this is how mitch mcconnell applies to
the federal society he goes
fun fact i mean it's true this is real
that's real that's how it works 100 real
feral society just got 1.6 billion
dollars by the way
the largest
largest individual contribution 1.7
billion dollars who got that the federal
society oh good would they need that's
good
no do we know who where they got that
yeah where an jewish dude with no
children uh sade i think his name is the
guy who the jews why have you done this
the guy the guy who own why why have you
done this
he just likes it he just rides he just
rides for [ __ ] christian supremacy oh
not good man back it up uh micro uh what
what the [ __ ] is the it's like some
electronics company yeah
he literally just like took over his
electronics company shifted it over to
it uh you know in order to avoid paying
uh like nearly half a billion dollars in
taxes on it
he took over the electronics company
that he owns 100
and shifted it over to a non-profit
uh and then and then shifted that over
to uh leo our boy at the federalist
society um
[Music]
so now he has 1.6 billion dollars here's
mitch mcconnell applying for grand
wizard of federal society
black people need to pick themselves up
by the bootstraps yeah it's the problem
with the black community watch out ethan
you're you're too good at that
okay let's play let's play um rhonda
santos's top gun ad
you want me to play yes please
oh wait this is my screen i got it okay
topgov
good morning ladies and gentlemen this
is your governor speaking today's
training this is worse this is worse no
it is this is like so much campier on
not on purpose oh no it is on purpose
these are all theater kids no
not like an arts program because they
can't solve it you're insulting ethan
with that he's he's a theater kid no i
know i'm not i never took a theater
class in my life well i've seen those
sketches okay you're a theater kid i
never took a theater and by the way
what's wrong being a theater kid right
there's nothing wrong with being a
theater kid you you you're just you're
telling me something i'm not okay uh
yeah well defensively yeah you're
getting a little too defensive there i
think you definitely are a theater kid
but
um
all right i like to i like to dress up
and play pretend everywhere but there's
nothing wrong with that you just you
have a healthy outlet for it okay you do
it you do sketches you do stuff like
that and it's funny and it brings people
joy this [ __ ] on the other hand
has that can't do it because like oh i'm
not gay i being a theater kid would mean
that i'm gay so i can't do that so then
it like builds this like pent-up
frustration from nothing that created
the adequate creative outlet i disagree
with you because it doesn't look like
he's having fun he looks like totally
serious he's not even trying to portray
a human being he's portraying like a
[ __ ] like again a reanimated corpse
of uh satan's
i mean the acting is
good morning ladies and gentlemen this
is your governor let's just watch it
today's training evolution dog fighting
taking on the corporate media the rules
of engagement are as follows number one
don't fire unless fired upon but when
they fire
you fire back with overwhelming force
can you pause for a second
like
this is this is incredible because like
he he nails it right like the american
couch potato consciousness has only one
like the only way that you can show in
the american country of consciousness
like your act of bravery is by what
[ __ ] yelling at the media that's it
that's what he's like equating like
being a
brave air force veteran this is stolen
valor brother how [ __ ] dare you sir
yeah you never even blew up a [ __ ]
iraqi grocery store yeah that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] like you know kill a couple
children and then we'll talk right well
he killed a bunch of people in florida
but
yeah his death toll is probably higher
than hers yeah that's true all right but
here my favorite part is coming up
with overwhelming force
does it say that in the bill
this this is his
attack with overwhelming force is him
going does it say that in the bill yeah
it's like oh
owned what the [ __ ] dude but down to the
sas this is so trump like the so trump
is like incredibly sassy he's a media
demon that's why i love him obviously
greatest president of our generation of
our time possibly of all time um but ron
desantis is like trying to be
i said this earlier on my stream too but
like he's trying to be cardi
like he's trying to be trump he's trying
to do a trump you will never be trump rd
yeah like playboy cardi
is that a say is that a thing that you
should just yeah she's trying to be like
cardi yeah trying to be cardi okay
you heard me here guys
uh let's watch this
i'm asking you to tell me what's in the
bill number two overwhelming force
never ever
back down from a fight if i could
complete the question by the way the
same press
conferences so you're gonna give a
speech or ask a question oh
never back down from a fight
this guy's a scrappy [ __ ] dude man
yeah he bowled never backstage this is
this this works though because like yeah
if you're like a 75 year old retired you
know [ __ ] police chief or whatever
that's now living in boca raton you're
like yeah that's right that's perfect
yeah he doesn't back down that's why i
like him he gives he sticks it to the
man the man is uh liberal media
that's it
that's the one thing they have that's
how trump was popping too so that's what
this santa is trying to do as well i'd
i'd be more impressed if i knew if he
blew up a single family home in iraq
yeah well he didn't do it he's this is
stolen he's a coward
number three don't accept their
narrative wrong it's a fake narrative i
just no matter what just abused you of
the narrative and you don't care about
the facts it's why people don't trust
people like you because
uh i mean
there's two angles to this right on the
one hand you're like oh i you know what
i look for in a guy that i want to vote
for for governor
a guy who's yelling at the [ __ ] tv
he's against a guy who's yelling at the
tv
press conferences he's the man but also
because we are so far removed from like
legitimately enacting any sort of like
political uh
political interest
because we're so far removed and the
american electorate from like actually
demanding our politicians do anything
yeah it does reduce to like is this guy
just like me he is just like me i yell
at the tv when i'm watching it and i say
oh cnn clinton news network and he's
doing it on the tv yelling at the tv
people so that is kind of like very uh
impactful it's it's you know he knows
his audience he knows his target
audience and he's reaching them this way
i guess so
let's go
[Music]
don't put your kid in a fighter jet
i mean yeah that one's way worse in my
opinion no that's age-appropriate dude
all right so the pizza is getting cold
so we better move on to that oh god okay
it's getting dried out and i do need um
it at peak performance to get a
get an accurate read from you
but one other thing i want to while
they're setting that up i want to show
this picture
here's desantis uh pretending to be a
real human being
check him out just stand just two dudes
stand in
just two dudes being two dudes normal
normal normal hand placement normal arm
placement
look how natural he is man he's a real
dude right there boy yeah is this part
of him trying to emulate uh trump's
style because i think trump has power by
the way landing ability too while
they're bringing out the pieces if you
want to see what a what a [ __ ]
conservative theater kid looks like i
present to you clay higgins uh this is
have you guys ever seen this i don't
think so this is a classic dude he goes
to the holocaust i got it
oh you got it yeah
all right let's see this is one of my
favorite videos of all time clay higgins
is is a theater kid with a lot of like
uh suppressed theater kid energy that
manifests itself in this way let's take
a look railroad anywhere right
except for this one's at auschwitz
birkenau
the expansion of auschwitz
where four more large gas chambers were
built
they could murder 2 000 people at a time
on these rails
oh wow out of those pools you got b-roll
cinnamon
roll bro i'm telling you i don't want to
know where this is going
to say as many as this oh these are not
now no
no
so [ __ ] to say that there's just
something so incredibly funny about like
this fat headed man okay
who is well you don't even know where
it's going yet just watch but like i'm
dying to know how he's got his phone
camera up to his face because they
probably told him he can't [ __ ] film
like that yeah yeah yeah no so he's like
secretly filming himself trying to be
pensive and thoughtful with the build up
to the one of the greatest moments yeah
i think i'm just i'm dying to know how
he connects auschwitz and the holocaust
to american politics oh just [ __ ]
weight 20 25 of them died on the train
because sometimes the trip was seven
eight ten days
had no food or water
mm-hmm
this is not [ __ ] appropriate you can
move it a little bit forward uh you can
you can skip a couple steps here
the pop inside i see this is where
people watch so oh my god dude what the
[ __ ]
did this guy win just tell me that oh
yeah oh yeah he's in here
yeah he's one of my favorite he's
probably my favorite american congress
person okay good to know i'm fascinated
by him
oh freeze frame bro slow zoom bro he's
got dude look at the [ __ ] face wait
right up in his face
wait wait hold on no they told him you
can't film in here bro
that's 300 000 did he where did he run
this is just a video he made just just
keep going all right
i think it's like when he's in the gas
chamber where he pops off like like he
just says
he goes echo echo no no no no no he's
not that's what makes it that's what
makes it funnier like he's so
he is so serious right
wait where is the message most replay
part i think that's right there's
there's right here and a little bit
further here play that play that part it
might be this one
cyclone b
actual cans
turn it up used to kill
1.1 million
whoa
well oh
here in auschwitz
said it would squeeze 700 people in here
oh this is it this is the one
the guards
would drop
[Music]
cyclone v
cyanide gas
from above this is
i mean he's doing he's doing he's doing
holocaust uh
i don't know just wait but how does this
tie in how does this tie into like a
really important video he's doing i
think it's good that people learned
about this never again
and even
can we not at this time this is a
serious moment of reverence
when they hit oxygen
after about 20 minutes
everyone was dead
[Music]
and then slave labor
would
go into the room and drag those
the bodies of those
poor souls out
and bring them and incinerate them in
these ovens
jesus christ
there
i think this is the three sets of ovens
like that
this is why homeland security must be
squared away
yes
yes
that's right
wait i gotta do that again you missed it
he did a brief pause i gotta pause after
the oven thing and he was like
now now it's time to pop off i'm clay
higgins and i got a message for america
this is why homeland security must be
squared away
security
security what like against like mexican
immigrants i mean that's just what he's
just saying like
he's like yeah
america's homeland security is is
supremely important
why because otherwise the holocaust will
happen to america if holocaust is going
to happen in america it's going to be
homeland security that throws people in
the oven no well he's talking about like
zlatan maybe he likes the holocaust no
no he does
like yo how dare you how dare you take
that back well i don't i don't know how
i'll see when there's a single teardrop
falling down yeah i don't know
yeah for the nazis because he's sad
they're gone
i don't i don't get it he's like no yo
this [ __ ] we can do this [ __ ] yeah no
fun homeland security the funniest part
about is like i mean the darkest part
about it at least is like he's talking
about zyklon b right yeah and and that
is like you know a chemical agent you
can bring the pizzas out sam chemical
agent that was used in the burcero
program which was like uh kind of the
the underpinnings are the architecture
for literally that and segregation in
the south was like something that hitler
looked at and was like that's pretty
good like we should do that in germany
he did it we learned it from you dad
yeah so like him talking about zyklon
being that respect and then turning
around and be like that's why homeland
security is so important is is a
hilarious juxtaposition but the reason
why i showed this to you is because clay
higgins is a rugged guy he's a tough guy
he's a sheriff right and he has a lot of
videos from back when he was a sheriff
like where he would have like uh all of
his his units sit there with like you
know 100 grand worth of equipment and be
like we're coming after you and he would
like call him out by name uh and and
that is like repressed theater kid
energy which i really love when it
manifests itself in this like wonderful
uh it's kind of interesting because he
could pretty much say anything after
this
like three minutes of horrific
concentration kept footage he's like and
that's why we need to subsidize corn no
yeah he's like that's why we need tort
reform
and that's america's greatest threat is
the is the lawyer the big lawyer lobby
and this is why we need to cut corporate
tax rates
evolving is like that oh i want to see a
little bit more
sam did you hear me
yeah uh we we have like a we have a
stinger we got a whole intro okay okay
so when you're right
homeland security must be square i just
want to hear where this goes our
military must be
invincible
it was the military that did this you
understand that right yeah no this is
the
okay whatever wow what a psycho all
right let's do our pizza segment here uh
let's just be two cool dudes like these
two guys here
absolutely hell yeah all right ian when
you're ready all right let's do it
okay i see that that's the regular
gloves microwavable pizza not microwave
you put in the oven dude dude you're
such a [ __ ] classes dude grow up yeah
i'll show you the brands that i really
like the frozen pizzas
[Music]
[Music]
hey hey oh yeah hey welcome to my
pizzeria sun
my son is seven percent italian so uh
this is what happens when you have a
seven billion dollar studio all of a
sudden boom tragically we're in a
different we're in a different set
welcome to my
pizza today i have a fight
what
oh i can't drink non-diet either wait
really i'll take i'll take a sip
i'll take a splash
today i present you with my finest
pairing of my old fine mountain dew
please have a sip
pizza is actually very nutritious
cheers
ah you can taste the uh
you can really taste the earthy flavors
and the
the yellow 17. yeah this is uh this is a
good it's got a oaky undertone you can
really taste the um
the top god that looks terrible oh god
the only thing you want fresh okay the
only thing you asked me
was whether i eat pork or not but you
didn't ask me if i i don't eat dog food
i don't eat there's no seafood okay i'm
just saying i'm just saying why don't
you eat seafood first
yeah also yes you are insane because
this entire thing that we're doing is
insane well you haven't even tasted it
you collapsed this pig yeah
i'm putting your head in the guillotine
pizza across the board is the is the you
know sustenance of the proletariat
having pizza's expensive dude having it
be frozen or uh delivered uh from
domino's is not going to change the
price point all that much
all right stop talking [ __ ] and let's
start eating
um
so can you so let's do this one first
okay can you guys show which one it is
i believe that is the california pizza
kitchen white pizza can you show the box
please
uh i'm i'm holding it up there we go
california now this is a good brand i
like california pizza kitchen frozen
pies they do
go ahead and grab a slice place this on
and take a take a bite of a fair bite
you know one bite you know the rules
cheers
let me show you the size of that bite
there you go that's fair
don't pretend like that's bad
it's an unorthodox pizza it has the
consistency of cardboard that's what's
been sitting out
pretend that it's fresh
okay
it still has the consistency of car i'm
pretending it's fresh pretend harder
okay do you want me to be honest or do
you want me to just like say it's good
no be honest
okay
um a lot of garlic yeah yeah a lot of
garlic
um that's good right
indiscernible uh the weird green stuff
which i assume is spinach yes that is
spinach
i love mmm i love frozen spinach on on a
topped on
globs of like weird white cheese things
i'm a fan of white i mean what is this
look at your classes bro i'll have a
white pizza every now and then right
like i'm not i'm not against it i'm not
completely against it
but i will admit i'm the expert on this
i worked at california pizza kitchen for
five years so
um uh it is a spinach garlic ricotta
mozzarella parmesan romano asiago cheese
he has no pizza experience
the garlic sauce all right let's move on
then this one's an f i get it fine what
did you what did you wait what do you
grade it i mean i i i'll that's not yeah
american let's not do the american let's
do like a one out of ten it's not my
favorite one out of ten one bite you
know the rules i'm gonna give this
i'm gonna give this a three
i give it a five because
it's not fresh but for me that's that's
good enough to enjoy now this is the um
barbecue chicken pizza what's this one
uh i believe that's also
can you cue up the boxes oh this one's
got it this one is also calculated it's
a kitchen
it's got okay so first of all do you
like barbecue chicken uh no okay i i do
like barbecue chicken not on pizza but
that's me i'm a buffalo chicken pizza
fan from new jersey but i will say this
um first scent it does have a a uh you
know
shoe left at the uh locker no i see it
there is a
the barbecue sauce does have a foot like
uh scent to it
that's a lie okay i'm gonna take another
i'm gonna take a bite
i'll give you a little dainty little
bite
it's not fresh the cheese is so leathery
oh it's not
it literally doesn't like
oh god that looks terrible that one
doesn't look good i agree no that one
looks horrible
um what do you give this one
um uh
a four
better we're improving uh better but
still somehow worse
ethan
for me honestly
i'll give it a five again it's hard to
really enjoy it
it's basically stale i see i see what
you're doing i see you're you're gonna
you're gonna keep saying it's stale on
everything
though
i mean i'm pretty sure even if this was
like fresh out of the oven it would
still be pretty pretty bad dude dave
portnoy even did a review of amy's pizza
and you gave it like a seven he said
this [ __ ] is insanely good is this what
we just had what is this one no that was
trader joe's as a matter of fact the
next one is amy's pizza he gave this is
seven david not this one the margarita
which we'll get to okay i'm just gonna
keep it real if dave portnoy said the
brand that gave us this green [ __ ]
got a sev okay first of all at least
it's like spongy the the crust is like
kind of spongy it's different than the
other ones the other ones just look like
uh dried out tortillas that you you know
put slabbed a little bit of [ __ ] uh
you know sauce on
this at least has like a thicker
uh crust so i it's not necessarily a
good thing i do i do value that i'm
gonna do something unorthodox here i'm
gonna try a bite from the backside here
oh because i want to see what the crust
uh tastes like ahead so again this does
look like [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie
oh
no
that tastes like cafeteria pizza
that's not good no
no
you know
okay amy's oh it's a spinach pizza
that's why it's so
oh no
that one that that's a no-no that's a
no-no no oh no no no give it a rating
it's not that bad stop it zero
zero you said one to ten mcqueen dude
what do you mean it's [ __ ] disgusting
it's edible it's more than edible i'm
putting this in africa could have eaten
these slices okay well you knew i was
not going to eat these though
okay so far not good can i put this can
i put dispose of the trash on it okay
this one's a four four for you it's not
so four
yeah i'm not a [ __ ] i'm not a [ __ ]
elitist pig dude you're you're a
proletariat salt of the earth
i'm a working-class hero look at his hat
we'll cook these this looks like dog
[ __ ] easy sam cooked them and they have
this and they have been sitting there
for
in the sorry warmer burnout this is
amy's as well because i'm noticing a
trend it's a it's a spongier crust this
one is also amy's this is their
margarita pizza this is the one dave
liked okay yeah so scent wise right off
the bat out of everything that i've
smelled so far this one resembles the
closest to a new york slice scent on
scent alone if you if i close my eyes
and you put this in front of me it
literally feels like
it smells like a new york pizza place
if it was like three blocks away you
know what i mean it's there's a subtle
there's like a subtle uh feel of it the
subtle taste of it
um okay i'm dying again
isn't that just darling
dave gave it a 6.4 for the 6.4 a lot
creamier
a lot creamier but in a good way
the cheese is not as leathery
the quality of the cheese is a lot
higher i think on this one
this is edible i'm telling you if it was
fresh this is the first time i mean it's
still warm it's not that bad
come on this is the first time somebody
taste the spy and just tell hassan how
much better this [ __ ] would be okay but
he doesn't trust me apparently okay i
don't know why you're getting so upset
because this is about pizza hassan you
may not be aware but this is this is a
big part of ethan okay that one is
actually good i'll give it a five all
right okay that's a five still doesn't
come near like a legitimate genuine
authentic uh new york piece of slice
honestly i also give it a five i didn't
find it oh
interesting surprising we have some
conversions you gave it up no you're
[ __ ] your your metrics are all out of
whack you gave that spinach [ __ ] a four
and then this a five
[ __ ] your mom yeah how about that that's
i like crazy one that's oh this is all
edible to me
okay no but like it being edible this is
all not be your only
metric for
i'll tell you what okay this looks legit
mad pizza is like sex you know what i'm
saying
uh this one is trader uh joe's or
uh great and when it's bad it's still
pretty good
[Music]
[Applause]
we have sex organic three cheese pizza
from trader joe's here bring that on
over okay i'm gonna get the greasiest
slice
here you go but i will say i'm proud of
you you're taking you're taking a
respectable bite so that's that's all i
could ask okay this one does not have
the prior scent of like the garlicky
the the garlicky uh scent that you can
like you could like in the previous
pizza that i had it you could
i knew that it was a pizza this is
this could be anything
it doesn't smell like it it just smells
like kind of like cheese like small
pizza yeah it doesn't smell like pizza
at all it has no sat
i don't like it
that's horrible
it's all right it's better than the
other ones that i've had
not the last one but um yeah i'll give
it a i'll give it a four as well
wait not good
you're saying it was horrible it's a
four yeah because i'd still eat it i
still eat all of it
all of yours you've given everything a
five or a four if so far that's what i'm
saying i could never rate a pizza lower
than four and four is like the four is
your zero five is i do know what you
mean though pizza is like sex like even
if it's bad you're still having sex even
if it's bad
i put my dick on it
before i eat it
all right this one is also trying to
look good okay this is trying too hard
this one is a little try hard yeah this
is a roasted garlic and pesto people
look at it with crust on this deep fried
crust this looks good as [ __ ] yeah oh
deep fried crust yes
it's also trader joe's but it's like
their fancy one cheers this one this one
looks interesting yeah
it's got
it's got like a little glob of pesto in
the top here i'm gonna try the deep
fried crust though i have to i must hmm
[Music]
like this is like having imagine it's
fresh though
it's pretty bright this one's pretty
bright
[Music]
this is like having it's so greasy
it's greasier than the other ones yeah
definitely
[Music]
this is like having
a reheated garlic bread
okay you know what i mean that's just
pretty good that's what it tastes like
it's like
it was garlic bread at a certain point
but then like someone reheated it and
the consistency of it is like
yeah i don't know i just
rating it's not great uh
three and a half
whoa oh my god bro we're not on the same
page what do you what do you what
[Music]
thank you everything's fine
your scores are in a very narrow range
here ethan i can't open it five is where
i bought them out i'm just being honest
okay
no you said four was where you bought it
four was like that was that outlier that
one they're running points in here
there's like there's like a constant
back and forth pizza running operation
all right this one uh
oh dude another bbq chicken this is
another barbecue chicken dude what the
[ __ ] that you know what this looks like
this is a pigeon meat that you would get
it like [ __ ] halal guys you know what
i mean which is delicious by the way
i'll still [ __ ] eat that [ __ ] but
it's like browned out
it is like the most oh god you can't who
which one is this this one looks
horrific okay trader joe's barbecue
chicken it hit me right in the face like
i got a waft of onion okay i think it's
undercooked i'm just saying who cares
what you believe
river the critic ethan i just i can't
i'm just saying i'm just saying
i have a lot riding on this that's a
three you and i'm just saying that's a
that's a two
not a three it's a two oh four it's bad
and that's a four for ethan okay it's
very bad it's not
all right
disgusting
i gave this finished one a zero right uh
yes i wanna maintain like i wanna make
sure that there's integrity in my in my
uh uh you know in my process here you're
you're kind of all over the place you're
giving everything fours and fives like
i'm trying to make sure that the range
is adequate
cut them off
the only thing we've learned from this
is that you'll just eat anything if it's
pizza well yeah and we already knew that
but i'm just being honest like these are
all
very edible pies all right what i would
destroy without a second thought the
next one
this one's kind of an outlier this is
probably the the fanciest woman am i
reading that correct does that say
prosciutto
yes and arugula and uh
bring it out
technically it's it says it's a
flatbread
not a pizza but
oh yeah i feel like a qualifier
prosciutto
frozen [ __ ] prosciutto in a room hold
on this looks good bro this is literally
like having caviar pizza but it's like
frozen you know what i mean not
beautiful
it's very it's a fat one that's a fat
one
well because it's it does they tried too
hard they tried too hard
and it's not even like okay
this
flat bird is supposed to imply that it's
like at least a little the crust is
supposed to be a little hard
yeah this is i am not touching that
prosciutto because that is like oh
that's key that is literally that
prosciutto obviously
that prosciutto has turned into uh it's
it's basically hard
it's like red and hot you didn't like it
huh sons of [ __ ] yeah you got to get
from the middle that's right
[Music]
oh
come on it's not that bad oh stop it
[ __ ] you son
that no i could swallow it but i'll be
honest i'm gonna give it swallow it okay
that one's a zero by the way that one
i'm going to give a three and [ __ ] you
what is my lowest rating yet that is
your lowest rating yet that's a zero
that was not good what did we learn from
this we learned don't try too hard the
margarita pizza is fine um can i get a
napkin too
[Music]
is there any don't give him a napkin
olivia yes uh the the amy's margarita is
the champion right now with the highest
my favorite is coming up which is trader
joe's pesto pizza uh oh yes that's my
fave
wait uh-oh i thought we already did that
one
no we didn't yeah we did trader joe's
pesto pizza
with tomatoes and pesto
yes okay so
this one spinach
oh okay so they don't have the one i
like sold out because it's so good right
probably perhaps that's a [ __ ]
nightmare this is a mushroom and black
truffle this is a [ __ ] nightmare why
is this happening to me i came to prove
a point and i don't even like any of
these
this is
oh dude it's like so oh dude it's you
guys you know that when you take it out
of the oven it's okay but it's both
soggy
but also like spongy at the same time
put it in the microwave to heat it up
trader
you don't that goes to a pizza
uh sam bought a toaster oven for this
yeah it's a toast not a microwave
a fancy one the biggest toaster oven
i've ever seen
as a matter of fact gordon ramsay would
[ __ ] execute both of us right now if
you saw us eating fake truffle pizza
that's frozen
that one sounds good what makes you
think it's fake truffle that [ __ ] was
forged by the finest truffle yeah dude
totally
[Music]
um that one is not as offensive as i
thought it was going to be
because like the presentation alone
makes it seem like it's not edible
so
it's surprising when you taste it and
it's not like immediately hitting you
directly in the mouth it's not
assaulting me
um in the way that i expected it to
because of how awful it looks yeah so
i'm gonna give that a four a pleasant
surprise what's interesting about it
being truffle is that it looks like
there's mushrooms growing on it so
that's the first time i've seen it yeah
it's black mold
this is you're we're ingesting black
molding that's it that's interesting
that they do that yeah
that's a floor it's so moldy that your
landlord would paint over it with a
white paintbrush right and forget it was
no yeah pretend it was never there and
what did you rate it ethan it's a four a
four so you guys are aligned on that one
yeah okay we've had two of those so but
for you you're surprised how good it is
and i hated it and we're both at four i
mean i'm not surprised i'm surprised how
good it is because it looks like it's
lethal yeah no i i get you so that's not
exactly like i'm not like delicious like
i would never order a single one of
these ever again for the rest well you
know what's good about that pizza you
eat the truffle and then you can grow it
afterwards yeah if you save a slide yeah
interesting
is there more i i think that that was
the end of my stack over here so um
i'm sorry i did that to you bro that
wasn't worth it at all that was all bad
what were you expecting you thought that
this was gonna be like a pleasant
experience when it comes out of the oven
when i make it at home those slap hard
i'm just but but today i gotta say
whatever happened here
it was not good well we don't own an
oven i know i'm not blaming you guys i'm
not blaming sam's been up since 5am
making pizzas yeah it's fine you guys
were eating them too quick for the
toaster to heat them up so i had to nuke
them in the microwave it's not your
fault sam you did the best i mean you if
you can't it's like you cook the pizza
in the morning it's you have no other
choice
you bring it in i'm not listen now you
guys made me feel bad i'm just being
honest okay thanks ian
no
[Music]
anything else you want to say to make me
feel horrible during the show
go ahead
hey sam if you feel horrible remember
we had to eat them
you guys dissed my favorite one which
was the truffle mushroom but try it you
try it okay so you'll be a good
impartial judge try it why isn't your
light ons man
you're like a pitch black darkness back
i know my
my mic's not working but
sam you didn't make the pizzas you guys
give me a [ __ ] break i mean yeah i'm
not i'm not i'm not criticizing sam how
dare you she's a pizza connoisseur stop
it well you know ian put this idea in
everyone's head
really it really wasn't me i saw i saw a
comment saying i'm really disappointed
in the production value today guys it's
it's lacking oh
so okay i i promise you oh it's the
commenters
yeah no i was seeing comments okay all
right well then [ __ ] chat traitor [ __ ]
you guys appreciate sam's work what is
sam saying
trader joe made this it's not on me no
first of all the logistics of sam
cooking all these is is is a lot okay so
you did an amazing job that being said
try the truffle one on camera please she
did oh she did how did you like it
be careful
she's
[Music]
i think it's like a six or seven right
now
but when it comes out of the oven it's
an 11.
out of 10. yeah okay everyone here is
broken okay
i saw what abe abe ate that thing last
week like i just i'll i'm just going to
be honest with you uh hassan you keep
talking that way and when the revolution
comes you're the first head on the
guillotine bro i mean that that's
already going to happen regardless i'm
the largest man in america that's true
according to internet anarchist you like
it yeah
i don't know man it just does the
freshness factor
look if i'm in a desert and i'm dying
okay because i survived the [ __ ]
plane crash and
the only form of sustenance i have is
that spinach pizza i'm dying i'm taking
the elf yeah let me put it let me know
the spinach one if they are like hey
here you go like you haven't had food in
a week like this is what we gotta be
like put me back in the desert i'm gonna
[ __ ] die this is what i'll say about
it okay if i was in a house full of
delicious fresh food and i opened the
freezer and saw that i cook that and eat
it happily and have a great time
who cares what you believe four thank
you jordan jordan is right on that
cheers well at least we can agree the
mountain dew is [ __ ] a fine vintage
fine fine yeah this is a vintage one
[Music]
i mean could you pick up those
those fruity
earthy the citrusy undertone yeah yeah
yeah yeah delicate this one yeah yeah
yeah
this one was produced in a kansas
manufacturing facility i can really
taste the
the rat poison in it right
very good very nice touch on this one
i can taste the bpd that it was held in
yeah good undertone of
microplastics yeah hey and if you're
watching from europe get [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can't have this because the european
food and safety commission decided
yellow seven and all these other food
dyes are you know
dangerous chemicals
yeah
no
[ __ ] up
they accepted it but i think they
changed their formula
for you just for them they're like
americans can suck on the poison yeah
yeah we have once again yeah that's why
they drink fanta instead they're big
fanta heads out there
the fanta is different color here than
in america i noticed man uh mountain dew
is uh japan and parts of europe banned
it because it until recently contained a
flame retardant
oh that's good i mean you you if it was
a flame accelerator should i go back i'm
going back to my place yeah you can go
back
get out of my face all right
you [ __ ] elitist
yeah if a flame a flame retardant i mean
that's great i'm not gonna get i'm not
it's gonna lower my flammability right
as long as it's not an accelerant
hook me up
uh they're saying they have mountain dew
in europe so and again another class is
moved by hassan who hates the poor oh
oh don't don't you dare uh don't you
dare disrespect my bona fides as a
mountain dew boy i'm a soda boy to like
die okay i have all i have every i i get
like signature mountain dews yeah i know
you i know you're dave i know your dude
i love coke zero that's my [ __ ] bro i
love coke zero i'm a diet coke uh boy
i'm a dc i'm a dc boy love that
the final scores are amy's margarita got
the the highest uh grades from
across the board sure
yeah
i love you of the work you've done sam
you are incredible you have worked all
morning thank you to bring us these uh
horrifically disgusting pies don't worry
about it but you didn't cook them
i did you
did i cook them you didn't cook them did
you
i i
i didn't no yeah
i was looking for no all right i didn't
cook them i was looking
i don't know if you guys are interested
in the stats but that uh really doughy
one has 300 calories the entire thing or
one slice the entire thing one slice has
430 calories that's disgusting oh wait
was that the one with the four it has
four the deep fried crust yes
400 calories for one of those yeah
and then the arugula one that you guys
hated is the lowest cow the lowest fat
everything across the board the honey
that one that one was like
i mean a lot of the pizzas that we just
had are are basically mres i'm going to
keep it real with you ethan i think you
would like me already it sounds like
ready to eat uh like version of this
yeah it sounds like those pizza are
pretty pretty good
mama mia 400 calories okay well this is
you already did so much italia phobia by
forcing me
a an ally to the italians to consume
this food you're not a you're not an
ally i am an ally to italians you're
ready to throw them in the [ __ ]
chambers bro i don't know what you're
talking about i was up to you you'd cook
them in the oven with the pizzas bro i
would never do that that's extra
seasoning
how dare you
yeah uh we have so much more to talk
about i guess we have a little time left
i know you you have [ __ ] to do usually
but yeah
this i'll just throw up some really good
ones crowder stephen crowder who is a
comedian as you guys know fancies
himself
as a very very funny man
as you know conservatives are getting
better at comedy and it's making the
it's making liberals
afraid
he posted this
uh it's his justice catch
just as catchy
you wanted to you want to remedy that a
b or
you just got to pretend it didn't matter
shaky his hands were on the button and i
looked away and i had a little twitch i
apologize yeah i'll let it play out now
let's go [ __ ] nightmare you need
steady hands for uh to be a soundboard
guy you gotta deal with me for two more
days
just as catchy as if not more than baby
sharky says
so i'm already offended because baby
shark is the [ __ ] i [ __ ] with baby shark
yeah theodore loves that yeah it's
[ __ ] that he would come for baby
shark like this
yo you know baby shark's like the most
popular song on youtube i actually think
it is now it has like 10 billion views
yeah and it deserves it i can't think of
a song more worthy of that and i'll tell
you i'll tell you what the people who
made it it's just a youtube channel
called pink fawn
they've built a whole [ __ ] empire on
this song
we have stuffed animals a tent
pink funk tents bro you know what's
[ __ ] up 11 billion yeah guess what
that's what happens when you actually go
viral and you haven't made videos
disparaging uh our military veterans
here in america that's right psy
i didn't get it i don't get it you did
do that
gangnam style
oh yeah he he is like uh like a rugged
anti-imperialist i mean he's super
awesome like i think he like literally
wait hold on he's very anti-american
what are we gonna do about that he had a
he had we need to we need to send that
uh okay are you ready for this we need
to send that pseudo lesbian pilot to
bombing can i just explain can i just
explain something to you really quickly
kill those [ __ ] yankees size anti-us
pass services killed them all slowly and
painfully the artist wrapped at a 2004
anti-us protest wait that that maybe sai
needs to tone down the rhetoric a little
bit
kill the yankees what is he a
confederate well
we have been
pseudo occupying their country for like
50 years
they should be sucking our dick bro they
got k-pop because of us that's true i
mean that literally is true you're not
wrong about that dude thank me
personally for k-pop i'll accept your
thank-yous now
you could have a career with that
concert stage in opposition to the 37
000 us troops stationed on the korean
peninsula sai took the stage in gold
face paint and a glittery red outfit
then lifted a model us tank over his
head before smashing it the pieces on
the ground the performance was a
response to the death of two korean
school girls killed in an accident with
an american military vehicle
uh which by the way that's like what
america and american military bases do
all the time was it like the wife of a
diplomat who was driving drunk and
killed people and then left without
charge or was that somewhere else it
could have been somewhere very well
it happens
yeah that's not a good thing yeah
well sai listen
you're going to gangnam style yourself
into a [ __ ] assassination can i can i
read that can you ever do that
can i read the rest of the lyrics yeah
dear american is the name of the song he
said kill those [ __ ] yankees who have
been torturing iraqi captives okay kill
those [ __ ] yankees who ordered them
to torture okay kill their daughters
mothers
and fathers killed them all slowly and
painfully that's what he said what wait
wait who
is this
that's psy
yeah i mean why are we killing their
whole extended family
like due to americans what the americans
do iraq is what he's saying basically yo
this guy he's gangnam styling on uh the
military that's what he's doing he's
upon gangnam styling on the us military
he should go to the graves of [ __ ]
veterans and gangnam style on their
grave i mean he probably would if given
the opportunity it seems like he would i
would like when uh when george bush dies
i'd like to see a video where he gangnam
styles on his grave it's just like i
guess some people i guess some people
have animosity when you like bomb 40 to
90 of the every single town in north
korea
uh and then uh you know here he is put a
uh put a brutal
brutal military dictatorship that is
aligned with u.s interests in south
korea for many many years
only to be uh you know thwarted by other
us aligned hyper capitalist uh che ball
backed uh governments
bro this is my favorite thing i like
this i'm gonna gang gum style on your
grave is the best thing now
ultimately no he's so based uh anyway
okay shout out gang mr gangnam over
there yeah but anyway talking about
political uh
theater or this is how we got we got
here from baby shark just yeah yeah
musicians so steven crowder very funny
uh conservative on the right
he actually hired someone to make this
which is interesting he paid for this
and then he decided after seeing it i'm
going to post this
he should have never twitter and so bad
he shouldn't have done that and so here
it is guys uh without further ado i
think we might get claimed for this
though no if that's the baby shark
melody these guys are [ __ ] ruthless
man oh really
yeah
i'll play just a snippet maybe oh i'm
scared
i mean you really need about four
seconds to get the idea
[Music]
yeah that's it he just goes by them
farts do do do do do bite in farts oh
we're not listening to the whole thing
okay i love that biden sharks
and sharks do do to do and then he goes
with the pope got him what do do do do
with the pope do do do do do bite in
sharks it just keeps going
and going and then he says join the mug
club baby for more for more incredible
content like this like who's the target
audience
like children or adults with children
brains dude the whole [ __ ] thing it's
like he's that's the worst thing you
could say is he farts i mean what the
[ __ ] are you talking about hundred
dollars hundred dollars for more content
like just like this is the type of this
is the type of uh thing that like joke
that you would make if your parents are
mad at you about cursing so you're like
biden poopy biden sharded on the pope
uh the comments were incredible man he
got absolutely eviscerated
i said this is embarrassing even for you
let me keep going you're almost 40 man
and he got rationed hard this is 36 000
likes yep
he got clipped
oh god i gotta click more replies every
time i see the ongoing effort to groom
children and conservatives and
conservative is going well well that's
an interesting observation
yeah no that's like they're so bad at
making content that is not like
directly
that is not created for uh already
racist like 45 year old divorced dads
that uh
i i do not worry about them like
genuinely
genuinely changing the attitudes of like
a younger generation
uh she said and this is interesting
because he tweeted this the day before
he says
sleep tomorrow is war sleep well and i
wonder if this is what he meant by that
yeah
yeah he's been he's been working hard to
promote the mug club ladies and
gentlemen
yeah so that was a good that was a good
thing that happened
by stephen crowder ladies and gentlemen
of the comedian
very funny man yeah really funny i love
you maybe i'll even clap for him
and that would be the time to play the
domestic terrorist abu europe they just
like got a minute no i don't have a
minute just just hit the flocka
just hit [ __ ] yeah just hit the slip
walker [ __ ] it just say
oh here it is this is uh
he actually already did it here he is
gangnam styling on uh that's crazy
whose grave is this ronald reagan no
that's papa george bush oh that's george
bush
he can get some too he was a war
criminal as well yes though may or may
not have played a role in assassinating
jfk who knows he he actually it's a
little weird that he was in dallas that
day yeah a little weird can't recall
what he was doing in dallas that day so
strange
um you know
well well psy obviously uh is doing a
psyop is that a good psy oh
all right just now don't over compensate
this one
all right that i like i like those those
are good
this is great laura loomer
she's always
who lost tragically she lost to another
republican who isn't as crazy as her
right okay here's the thing if you can't
have someone more crazy than laura
loomer who like was caught on camera
talking to a literal nazi
uh saying like oh why won't you [ __ ] me
um
i have big ashkenazi tits and an
ashkenazi iq or something
like
she's just straight up
yeah she's just straight up told like uh
like an actual nazi like a white
supremacist on camera at a one of these
like [ __ ] awful you know virgin
events that they do that they throw
uh like why won't you [ __ ] me oh there
it is look so good you're like beautiful
thank you like an aryan degenerate
goddess thank you i love it thank you
dude dude white supremacist flirting is
so funny
you're like an aryan degenerate god you
are a perfect you are perfect we need to
breed
i know but i'm jewish
look at his reaction he's like oh wait
oh she said i'm jewish yeah is she
jewish yeah yeah she's jewish yeah wait
so what's going on here exactly what do
you i mean she's an idiot like go back i
thought she was just being anti-semitic
but she's actually jewish yeah this is
wild yeah no she is yeah
your eyes look so good you're like
beautiful thank you like an aryan
degenerate goddess thank you i love it
thank you
is it your aryan too wait wait i want to
hear what he said i wonder where you
feel go back he said muttered something
yeah you said you're
i know i'm jewish
it's okay that's okay
it is you got it i'm going to tell you a
secret like you know so many people in
this movement who preached that life are
like [ __ ] people on the side and like
cheating on their partners that's so bad
who why is this being silent
why not content because pleasure
um no it's great it's great he she has
the death grip on him too you notice
that oh yeah she's like
basically clawed his clavicle if a man
did that boy it'd be over man yeah come
on why won't you [ __ ] me
our big hits and an ashkenazi iq it's
like dude oh my god but i i like that
she at least acknowledges that her uh
her fellow republicans are anti-semitic
she's like all my other colleagues want
to [ __ ] kill me because the jews yeah
which uh
by the way that's just like that's like
the least offensive thing that she's
done for the record in a long sequence
of like you know being a proud
islamophobe she was so islamophobic she
got [ __ ] banned from like uber and
lyft and stuff
um she yeah she's
she changed herself to the twitter
headquarters in new york in a to stage
of protest because she got banned off
twitter i mean she's just such a sweaty
awful to look at laura horrible person
more like laura boomer from the looney
bin
hatred a-okay
band with a yuda stamp
wow girl
yeah let's watch she lost uh uh very
shockingly
we are losing our country because of big
tech election interference and i am
pleading with the republican party to
please start taking this issue seriously
is she crying
it's why i ran for congress in 2022 and
it's why i'm going to keep fighting for
all of you
you're fighting for me
with those big ass titties wait what was
can we pull up the election results
because like this psychotic person she
lost to a republican almost no no she
she almost won
it was a close [ __ ] race you mean i
could have seen those big ashkenazi tits
on [ __ ] every day
and she went to the village of congress
what's really funny about it is that so
the villages is like a famous uh you
know republican stronghold many people
have uh written about it extensively she
went to the villages and ran
an expressly and openly ages campaign
but but it's a retirement community full
of boomers and they loved it they were
like
like she said you know um congress can't
be run by like these old people you know
that need walkers and pacemakers that's
why you should vote for me laura loomer
and all these [ __ ] boomers with
walkers and pacemakers like yeah boomers
for loomer well nobody knows better than
them how right she is
yeah wasn't that close was it seven
point i mean it was it got real close
because of uh the way that the the
bowser being tabulated uh and for a
moment it was like what the [ __ ] however
this is still close because laura
[ __ ] loomer man like that's good yeah
my favorite thing about the
conservatives now is anytime any of them
lose even to other republicans it's it's
uh
rigged yeah
genuine belief that it was rigged
it's currently
this is ben shapiro's uh sister
she has some really sound dating advice
and she honestly
is giving dating i don't know what's the
context of the dating advice she's
giving
but it sounds out content all the time
but it sounds like she's describing
somebody yeah i can't figure out quite
who let's listen one thing that i
learned early on in my dating career was
i didn't want to date a guy i didn't
want to end up with a guy who felt like
he had to win every argument there are
some guys who really just think that
they need to be the smartest one in the
room all the time
and you can never get into just a
discussion everything turns into a
debate so i knew very quickly that i
never wanted to end up with a guy like
that one thing that is fair
to be fair that's crazy if you grew up
with benjamin in the household you would
run the [ __ ] away from ben shapiro
archetypes
as well
like can you imagine is she literally
just hypothetically hypothetically i
would not want to pass you the salt
because uh i'm a man and you should be
able to pass assault to yourself if
you're a woman and a feminist you should
be self-reliant here's actually ben
shapiro never forget this is real my red
pill moment came when i turned seven
years old my mom sent me to school with
cupcakes for my birthday and the teacher
made me share them with my classmates
even the poor ones whose mothers never
sent cupcakes for their birthday the
rage of that day has never left me
that's not a real sweet amount this is
not a real tweet i don't believe that
never forget
i don't believe that
73 000 likes yeah that's part of the
reason why i don't believe that because
that would have way more quote tweets
dude are you kidding me
if that was real it would have way more
quote tweets
um this is actually
not funny
it's incredible actually it's incredible
it's tragic it's fascinating
it's infuriating this guy south carolina
republican rep representative neil
collins
voted
to make abortion illegal in his state
and so soon after that there's obviously
dozens of horrific stories coming out
every day new stories are coming out
about just horrific violence and
horrible conditions that poor these poor
women who are trying to
uh you know
for so many reasons but anyway this guy
he's shocked by the result of of his
vote so here he is talking look at that
the consequences of my actions that's
crazy like on one hand i'm like
i'm glad he's at least
swallowing his pride and doing the right
thing and talking about this but on the
other hand it's like [ __ ] you you demon
everybody was saying this from the
beginning a thing that i can't say
uh on youtube that you told me not to
say is something that i really want to
say
honor
i'm just saying whatever you would say
would happen in minecraft if you had any
honor you would you know do the right
thing
here's the clip you guys are gonna if
you haven't seen i mean it's really
shocking i voted for the pain-capable
bill
the fetal heartbeat bill and fetal
heartbeat has been
for
six weeks now
the second week
that this that the fetal heartbeat bill
became law
a doctor called me
out of anderson i live in easley
a 19 year old girl
appeared at the er
she was 15 weeks pregnant
her
water broke
flanker
the fetus was unviable to that amy the
standard of care was to advise her
that they could extract
or she could go home
the attorneys told the doctors that
because of the fetal heartbeat bill
because that 15 week old had a heartbeat
the doctors could not extract so their
only choices were to
admit the 19 year old until that fetal
heartbeat stopped i asked how long does
it take to stop she said
seconds minutes hours maybe days
or discharge torture they discharge that
19 year old
the doctor told me at that point there's
a 50 chance well first
she's going to pass this fetus in the
toilet
she's gonna have to deal with that on
her own
wait why is he not talking about it like
a baby pause it for a second
wait i'm sorry is he saying fetus huh
that's not that's not the appropriate
terminology in this situation the
appropriate terminology is baby uh
that's a that's a potential baby that's
a different wife right right right right
yeah that's like oh she's gonna have to
murder the baby
yeah
that's so strange that she needs to
scoop it out and we need to bury it yeah
life begins at uh conception right so
what's up now it's a fetus you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] animal it's like did
you not read the [ __ ]
thing you signed but here let's let's
continue no they
they did it doesn't matter they're
[ __ ] brutal pieces of [ __ ] every
single one of these [ __ ] like
they deserve infinitely worse
if there was any sort of karmic justice
on this world they every single lawmaker
that has signed on for these [ __ ]
bills universally would feel a fraction
of the suffering that any amount of like
random 16 year old girls feel in these
[ __ ] states where they go to the er
and the doctor's like sorry
you're literally you're you're not
you're your fetus is not like uh dead
yet dead enough yet you have to continue
torturing yourself it has no head i
heard about this your fetus has no head
yeah it it it's it's has no head but it
has a heartbeat yeah we can't you have
to give birth to this we can't ease your
suffering you have to you know you have
to deal with it on your own let me ask
you this doctor can a baby survive with
no head
it's not a baby it's a fetus he's right
anyway he realizes that he is going to
hell as we continue
she's going to pass this fetus in the
toilet she's going to have to deal with
that on her own
there's a 50 percent chance greater than
50 percent chance that she's going to
lose her uterus there's a 10 chance that
she will develop sepsis and herself die
that weighs on me i voted for that bill
it should you're going to hell
yeah that's your fault the blood is on
your hands and you're going to hell
but at least he's come to god at least
he's come to jesus so to speak
no he should meet he should meet his
maker i think if he wants to come to
jesus in minecraft of course i'm gonna
i'm not saying anything i'm just saying
like you do the right thing you know
he's doing the right thing look i
already got a [ __ ] strike just chill
do that [ __ ] on your own channel
i mean i i do
yeah but i think you're fine but anyway
thank you almost for the tony gifted
thank you for the gifted
thank you for the gift thank you for the
20 gifted fetuses
i don't know if that's funny maybe too
far
but anyway here you're going to hell bro
these are affecting people
and we're having a meeting about this
it took
that whole week i did not sleep
oh oh
poor guy poor guy listen listen i have
no sympathy for any of these [ __ ] i
actually do like that he's saying this
this is important i like that he's
saying it because he does the right
thing then i'm on board a lot of people
in his position wouldn't either a give a
[ __ ]
or b would never admit this publicly so
on one hand you are a demon and you are
going to hell and the blood is on your
hands but on the other hand appreciate
you
the the thing is this was the
predictable outcome every single person
even dumb idiots like myself knew that
this was going to happen and said that
this was going to happen and there is no
adequate way of criminalizing abortion
without punishing women
every instance of like uh
every every time you try to stop someone
from getting a medical procedure you are
punishing the the the entire
marginalized population that you're
impacting
there's no way out of this they knew
that this was going to happen now
they're trying to make it seem like oh
well we didn't do carve outs but like it
was never supposed to be for people that
are that have ectopic pregnancies it's
like [ __ ] you dude that's exactly what
was going to happen and it is happening
yeah the zero tolerance policies in some
of these states it makes no [ __ ] even
if there was like minor
tolerance it still doesn't matter these
are edge cases that greatly showcase the
hypocrisy
and and the the lack of morals behind
writing legislation like this but even
then it doesn't matter even if it wasn't
an ectopic pregnancy women should still
be able to get an abortion whatever the
[ __ ] they want okay it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you are
you are causing them to carry
pregnancies to term which is torturous
it's literally a torturous process it is
torture it is state sanctioned torture
it's [ __ ] unacceptable i mean murder
in my opinion yeah
yeah it's it's it's horrific it's sad
it's so it's probably
it's so [ __ ] up i mean this is like
i i talked about it so much i mean
there's really nothing left to say about
it other than these people are going to
hell and it's just the natural reaction
is that a lot of women are going to die
and suffer needlessly
absolutely needlessly a bright young
promising
uh women and uh girls
are gonna die until everybody realizes
it's barbaric and it's sad that you even
have to [ __ ] do it it's gonna you
know it's gonna get reversed eventually
either at the state or federal level um
and and and there's going to be
basically carnage
in between that happened for no [ __ ]
reason thank you for the gifted
derrick ruins thank you for the gifted
good gift from david graham's thank you
okay a little awkward to transition
there if what what connection it was
just like in the same breath it was the
same sentence what can i do
you appreciate it
anyway yeah i don't have an ounce of
sympathy for these [ __ ] unless
they like literally are
like actively
like if you want redemption from the
horrifying actions that you took like
you need to either a do the right thing
and even in that situation your your
guilt is not absolved in my opinion like
i i believe in rehabilitation but these
sick [ __ ]
you can't get away with uh get away with
it by being like oh man
some women are suffering because they
had ectopic pregnancies that they needed
to carry
uh and and you know could potentially
die
uh it just made me lose sleep like no
[ __ ] do the right thing do the
right are you so cute when you talk [ __ ]
yeah i mean the the most it's all so
[ __ ] up and there's so many women
like abortion
and like if you have a
failed pregnancy
the procedure of safely removing the
fetus
is technically the same procedure that
you would do to get an abortion exactly
and so hospitals
the lawyers are telling the doctors you
can't even help women
whose bait whose pregnancy has obviously
failed and now is just a threat to their
life
and their health
they're saying you can't get an abortion
and like most doctors don't even want to
rock the boat they don't want to get
like in trouble they don't want to get
arrested so they're terrified of doing
this procedure but then some states will
literally go after the few doctors that
still bravely say [ __ ] that i'm doing it
right they will go after those doctors
as well and they will they will punish
those doctors as well it's such [ __ ]
dude there's some state where they're
trying to make uh abortion
homicide homicide what was that what
what state was that they're trying to do
some legislation i don't know i just
like
i had this this makes my blood boil like
i guess the only
there is no there is no positive outcome
out of this but uh you know they are
they are suffering electorally at least
because they followed through on the
promises they made to their most
louisiana most aggressive yeah louisiana
is trying to pass a bill no that's great
that's it angola needs more prisoners
like wonderful thank you it says
doing an abortion is murder which is in
louisiana punishable by death
love that i mean that's like the best
pro-life circle ever yeah you can't be
more pro-life than that
everybody dies maybe let's go they could
be gifted
yeah
it's cool oh thank you for the gifted uh
out wait is that a new one from alamos
yes thank you for the gifted i'll miss
thank you for the gifted
50 gifted
yeah so uh anyway
we're pretty much out of time uh i hate
to end on such a dark do we have
anything real quick that's funny that we
can
think about
it but 20 grand baby joe biden richard
that's only for people
45 million americans have student loan
debt uh i'm one of those people that
believes in personal responsibility i've
paid off my student loans and i think
it's frankly disgusting that i have to
pay for really [ __ ] up lazy
[ __ ] so you paid off your debt i
did so i think it's
sarcastic
i did two so i think it's only fair that
those here in the office that are
getting it need to pay us support is
interesting that is such a good point
actually i'll just i'll garnish it from
your
okay
i love that i paid off my student loans
and my brothers as well so you know i
need to i need to get doubly double up
yeah yeah what else next
um
i guess you worked at a soup kitchen
last weekend too
what what no i did not do that oh yeah i
mean like oh i'm talking about all the
good things i've done yeah yeah i'm so
nice i know okay that's such a good
person like bro i don't know what to say
but you were tweeting about how you got
your own hbo
go account and i'm like this
[ __ ] just bought a porsche and a
nice house and now he's talking about
buying hbo i know what what can i
purchase dusting stop selection
no it's that one that one actually hurt
a little bit i've literally i've had
that hbo max account that i've like
basically shared i was gonna say stolen
but shared with a friend of mine
for like the past you know however long
hbo was in existence and then turned
over to hbo max
um yeah yeah that hurt like even before
then even before hbo max existed or
before hbo go
i'll say this i went through every tax
bracket with it literally really every
single tax bracket with that hbo max
shared account i'll say this
i knew i had made it when i got my own
netflix account
yeah i was living a comfortable life
you're still using your mom's today i'm
still using my mom's yeah
but now at least i'm i'm paying it back
but with hbo max going because she was
always like trying to get me to
can you not watch two at once does it
kick the other person out or something
no so what's the problem
well i just didn't have it i didn't have
hbo max account i used my dad's serious
account so
he's we're still sharing
yeah but
now look now just because i
i conjure green flames to burn the souls
of the virgin women it doesn't mean that
the students need the ten thousand of
debt forgiveness
[Music]
yeah he's he's mad he's real mad he's
been uh he's been out of shape for this
one and i love that because you know he
loves he loves giving money to the
wealth oh wait there was one thing sorry
there was one thing i did want to do
before we go
is all the demon takes on the debt of
forgiveness i really wanted to look at
this okay
mitt romney who's worth half a billion
dollars
said it's sad to see what's being done
to bribe the voters biden's student loan
forgiveness plan may win democrats some
votes but it fuels inflation foots
taxpayers with other people's financial
obligations
[ __ ] shut the [ __ ] up dude that happens
all the time for big businesses all the
[ __ ] time and the one time that it's
like actual people in need like
individuals you [ __ ] about how it's not
the tax pay payers financial obligation
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] bro
he says it's unfair to those who paid
their own way and create irresponsible
expectations you know what bro you're
worth half a
billion dollars i said this before one
thing that is like really interesting
about this kind of commentary is that
he considers like something that's good
for the broader population 45 million
americans a bribe and it's like
dog yeah yeah yeah that's that's just
like good policy that's what you're
supposed to do but americans are so
brain broken into thinking like no no no
there's no such thing like you that's a
bribe you're doing something wrong if
you're like giving money back to the
voters
what you can do and what you should do
always is to just give money back to
corporations in the wealthy
those are the only people that matter
you can only bribe them if you bribe the
american people that's bad that's wrong
that's that's you're rocking the vote if
you try to give people health care it's
a bribe yeah they would they would be so
on board with it if like somehow this uh
if you if you just convince them that
like no no don't worry this is going to
exxon mobil yeah it's also this whole
thing it's not fair
it's not fair as i sit on a pile of half
a billion dollars
it's not fair you know it's not fair uh
being like uh executive at bain capital
and making billions of dollars firing
people apparently i read he makes like
six million dollars a month or something
to have the hoods but to be like it's
not fair yeah no
demon straight yeah straight demon
love that for mitch uh
uh good luck on your [ __ ] mitt romney
you know the liberal
as he said black lives matter actually
that's all it takes for the democrats
which is pretty radical for a mormon
i'll say that
well they did get the patch notes black
people are no longer they the mormonism
they got the patch yeah
they though or did they you know they
bashed it out like in the inner rings do
they because that's like deep
that's deep mormon lore is that black
people are literal i think they're
demons bro yeah when you're a bad person
you turn black literally that's what
they think that's in their their book
mormonism believes everyone will go to
heaven no matter what okay and that's
why they baptize people like hitler they
baptize hitler and anne frank um
post-mortem right that's yeah um however
the only people that will not go to
heaven are black people because they're
evil demons yeah mark mccain yeah yeah
yeah
crazy [ __ ] is that awesome yeah yeah
yeah they they say we patched that out
just like they patched uh polygamy out
come on i mean you can't get the whole
book just how they pass it out
you know what i mean like you know well
out there i mean his name is still
byu i'm just saying when you go into the
[ __ ] inner chamber of that uh
uh happy uh a small world after all
looking castle they have
um
they're they're talking about black
people aren't demons okay the one
final positive note to end it on though
with the student that forgiveness is
wait we're not done we have a lot of
these we got over here all right well
i'm keeping you here okay
so you want to make that point or should
we move on no here we can we can look at
a couple more of these but i i got to
run after all right let's do it then
don jr of course uh
dude who's famously
cancelling student debt is a tax on the
most responsible people in the country
not
forcing people who worked hard to repay
their loans or
or those who didn't have the luxury of
going to college to subsidize people who
wasted money on worthless gender study
degrees is a slap in the face yeah
that's
they're all have gender study degrees
they're
genius by the way this idea that it's
going to cause inflation is very
hypothetical i mean
it's really
it's really not
a given you know what i mean
uh demon uh mcconnell
has slapped the face of the working
americans who sacrifice to pay their
debt or made different career choices to
avoid debt a wildly unfair
redistribution of wealth towards higher
earning people [ __ ] you are such a liar
no he's just jealous high earning people
no he's jelly he's like only again to do
a reverse robin hood scheme like even if
this was that liar
even if even if it was that which it
isn't mitch mcconnell would only be
jealous because he's not the one doing
it
now now the one thing that is fair that
i like is you know or we bet we gave the
banks trillions of dollar dollars and
that that was fair that was a fair
moment there yeah
no no
wildly unfair distribution of wealth
towards higher urging people you liar
[ __ ] demon your hands are black your if
your opinions are invalidated
kevin mccartney of course said mccarthy
said biden's debt transfer scam will
make inflation even worse and does
nothing to stop the runaway costs of
college for most families well that's
true we need to go further we need to
address that yeah i know that's pretty
cool
but they always love they always love
using like one problem caused by
capitalism to to stop like one band-aid
solution to a capitalist problem yeah
but but also it's just totally virtual
signaling because they will have no
intention of ever addressing that actual
issue americans cannot afford democrats
radical agenda shut up [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
one trillion ppp how about you get this
pp in your mouth
[ __ ] kevin oh god
get this pp in that pretty little mouth
wow okay
okay wow demon ass [ __ ]
nikki haley says biden student loan
payoff is vote buying plain and simple
again another black pill i love that's
such a good point you make like anything
like wow you're buying votes yeah it's
that's called policy it's called
legislation like when you do something
good when you do something right by
people it's like wow you're buying votes
wow kindergarten bribed the [ __ ]
voters much yeah
it's like i can't believe you want to
fund the fire department uh drive try
harder to buy more votes
yeah poor people deserve to actually die
in a [ __ ] house fire you know
uh it will raise tuitions increase
inflation and add the liberal corruption
we see in government raise tuitions okay
price checks on college or shut the [ __ ]
up yeah
you're a demon you're going to hell oh
and then we have there's one really fast
i know you're in a hurry so i'm going to
move fastly oh my god oh god
he's got gray eyes that's not a good
sign
um
where's the one of the ppp boys
uh
oh it's it was right above that it's a
it's a separate uh album
okay so where is it
uh right here here i'll throw it up oh
yeah i got it i got it
okay so up again a conservative talking
point
very predictable stephen crowder of
course a legendary uh comedian on the
right made famously the uh biden farts
uh of fame student loan forgiveness
sounds really nice to illegal immigrants
why how did that even get i don't even
understand people with no life
experience and people who don't have
families yet and people who use
preferred pronouns
i mean got him
he uses pronouns too he has a preferred
pronoun yes he him yeah so i don't
understand
so then this there's someone who's
responding to all these [ __ ] with
like this bro got a fat handout from the
government 70 000
yeah so what's the what is the
difference exactly um
like genuinely what's the difference
that was the other dunk i that was the
other dog i had was like i think the 87
000 like kitted up irs agent should go
into the homes of every single person
who got a pvp loan that's like saying
that student loan debt forgiveness
should not happen and forcibly seize
their asses put a lien on the house put
a lien on the [ __ ] studio and sees
all their assets until they pay back
every [ __ ] dime of that loan that was
forgiven to the government
now i'm really curious what he would say
is the difference
yeah i mean because that's for
businesses ethan businesses know how to
handle the money whereas uh the 20 grand
that each individual you know person
took on or even more debt that they took
on to become a productive member of
society to to become a higher giving
you're giving the you buy it in too much
credit you keep saying 20k that's like a
very small percentage where's the pell
grants okay 10k yeah 10k
the lever uh the
let's see the conglomerate led by mitch
mcconnell's wife family received a loan
of 350 000 to 1 million yeah
firm run by u.s transportation secretary
elon ciao's family got uh yeah so she's
here's uh mcconnell's saying we already
read his right yeah so same thing he got
a fat [ __ ] hound out bro
we're talking about 10 000 this man got
up to 750 000 so that's a pretty good
deal for him
the worst is like a lot of these [ __ ]
demons took that money uh with
assurances that they were not going to
actually fire anybody
or or uh push for any sort of like pay
cuts on them and then they did that
anyway
white house is going to ask middle-class
families to pay 20 grand uh to
households earning a quarter million
dollars that's [ __ ] purple strategy
1.6 million
yeah this man got a free
1.645 million dollars bro whoa
every single mama every single person
purple pr every single person that is
like talk [ __ ] about this has either a
gotten their
rich parents to pay for their [ __ ]
college or b gotten a ppp loan or c both
okay both had their parents pay for
their [ __ ] college education and
gotten a [ __ ] ppp loan that was
forgiven so this struck me this man got
a 160
students worth of uh of uh
daddy's money there
[ __ ] [ __ ] i just don't know how
these people making a hundred thousand a
year look people in the face who change
uh seniors bed pants for a living or
drive a truck or work the railroads or
stock grocery shelves or deliver the
amazon package and say yes you give me
10k i just don't okay except like
those [ __ ] people are also people
that took those loans that will have
their debts relief so shut the [ __ ] up
look if you are a blue check media demon
okay and i myself am one of those people
as well i'm saying this demon the demon
shut the [ __ ] up okay all you do is post
and half of your posts are not even good
okay none of your posts are good all you
do is
chirp on [ __ ] twitter okay
that's how you make a living you get
paid like
200 300 thousand dollars with some
[ __ ] shady
uh shady like a hedge fund that owns
your [ __ ] corporate uh owns the the
corporate entity that owns your goddamn
dumbass [ __ ] newspaper that nobody
reads and then you [ __ ] [ __ ] on all
these people that are going to get debt
relief
her company got hundred thousand dollars
what's interesting about her is the
people she's describing are the people
with the student debt you think these
people are just going fast-tracked yeah
everyone knows 45 million people
took on student loan debt everyone knows
someone grocery store shelves student
debt everyone knows amazon package
delivery student debt okay here's here's
the funny part though truck driver
student debt everyone knows someone that
has taken on student loan debt or they
have taken it on themselves yeah but you
know you know unless you are one of
these [ __ ]
liberal elite institutionalist uh
[ __ ] media demons those are the only
people that don't know anyone that took
off student loan debt because those are
the only people that are coming from
rich enough families that didn't have to
take on student loan debt so they could
[ __ ] circle jerk on cnn msnbc fox
news about how like oh this is so [ __ ]
up isn't it [ __ ] up isn't it crazy
that these people are getting debt
relief like shut the [ __ ] up yeah she
got 700 000
they are they are already in noah's lane
they're already in elite circles and
that's why they can [ __ ] chirp like
this and try to divide and conquer the
working class and try to make it seem
like there should be resentment for
people who were able to pay off their
[ __ ] loans who suffered through all
of that those people should resent those
who got ten thousand dollars in relief
that's [ __ ] what's interesting about
betya
she says how do you look people in the
eye and said yes i get 100k i just don't
get that what i don't get is how you can
tell people that they can't get ten
thousand dollars relief when you're
[ __ ]
hurt the company's [ __ ] ass that's
seven hundred thousand dollars yeah
newsweek got seven hundred grand yeah
by the way bible is pro debt relief did
you know that from deuterono deuteronomy
15 at the end of every seven years you
shall grant a release of debt and this
is the form of release every creditor
who has lent anything to his neighbor
shall release it he shall not require it
of his neighbor or his brother because
it is called the lord's release where's
the lord's release you demon [ __ ]
i'm about to release this nuts on you
[ __ ] not her i mean mitch mcconnell i'm
not not doing any of that
hold on i'm coming but like i said
positive the positive note i would not
end this on the positive note i want to
end this on is that like all these
people that are really upset right now
are having a really hard time coming to
terms with the fact that 45 million
americans might have the capacity to
have at least some level or all of their
debt entirely removed their student loan
debt and they are the worst people so
just just celebrate this celebrate how
much they've gotten
celebrated out of spite
think about how much they're they're
angry think about how angry they are
that gives me joy that fills my heart
with joy in an otherwise really dark
time a dark period that we're living
through ladies and gentlemen we are all
domestic terrorists exactly
uh real quick this guy said this isn't
policy it's contemptuous abusive uh uh
unbelievably uh capricious yeah
capricious unbelievably expensive shot
in the dark uh this man got uh uh um 150
000
and uh
we are all domestic terrorists he's got
a big delay over there you got ping
yeah he's just ap he's got lag like he's
signing up from
he's on the korean server yeah uh
marjorie titan green says it's
completely unfair meanwhile this dummy
got 180 000 in pvp loan forgiveness
i mean
12 jobs
12 people all family members most likely
hired for her [ __ ] real estate
development company and she got 182 000
uh mark mark wayne [ __ ] has two
names together pick a lane pick a lane
wayne there's no such thing as a free
lunch oh really [ __ ]
explain this is a fat free lunch to me
seven hundred thousand
yeah it's great there's so many of these
yeah it's endless it's endless but
anyway there's our episode for the day
hassan thanks for sticking it out thank
you for uh even taking those bites of
pizza i know that was not easy for you
no no it was fine it was a way more
pleasant experience than i thought it
was gonna be
and you hate
at least i didn't at least i didn't
throw up that was that was what i was
worried about yeah
thank you to all of our beautiful
members thank you to derrick runts for
the gifted 50 they give it a gifted
and uh thank you everyone for watching
as always this has been a
leftovers episode we'll be back friday
for after dark thank you for watching
see you next week
yes so
as i was saying is that
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you